- Thank you for being on
my first show, Dwayne,
- Yes, thank you for having me.
- Very excited (audience
cheering and clapping)
- Before we get to anything
else, as I said before the break
you hadn't actually planned on being here.
Your baby brother, Kevin Hart,
because that's what you
call him, your baby brother.
- Yeah.
- He was supposed to be here
but he was in a car accident weeks ago.
So everything's good with
him now though, right?
- Everything is good.
I spoke with Kevin,
I actually refer to him as my son.
(Kelly laughing)
I connected with him today,
and you know what, these
things happen in life,
and thankfully, he -
- Right?
- he was strapped in
nicely to his car seat.
So I think that everything,
(Kelly and audience laughing)
(Dwayne laughs)
- Oh God, I love you! (laughing)
That's, like, that's real love.
- That's real love, guys.
- Love, that's love.
- Listen, I'm only kidding.
- Yeah.
- We spoke to the
pediatrician and he said -
(Kelly and audience laughing)
he's doing very well.
- Oh gosh.
- He is bummed he couldn't
be here, as you know.
But look, I love the guy.
He's one of my best friends
and honestly, I mean,
Thank God, it could have been,
could've been a lot worse.
So he is a lucky man.
- Yeah.
- And I'm so happy he's, you know,
(audience clapping)
yeah,
(audience cheering)
and he knows it too,
and I wish him the best
and speedy recovery,
and I'm gonna see him soon.
- And you two have the
best chemistry, like,
- We got a good chemistry.
- It's, I mean, I love every
film you've done together, like
I love you-all, and "Jumanji,"
I'm gonna be real with you, okay, Dwayne?
- [Dwayne] Oh, thank you (laughing)
- When I saw the preview
that they were doing
another "Jumanji," I was, like,
that's not a good idea.
(Dwayne and audience laughing)
'Cause, like, because like
the original was so good.
- [Dwayne] Yes.
- But, yours was amazing, like, I was -
- [Dwayne] Thank you.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] I freaked out, we have seen it.
- Thank you so much.
- We have seen it so much,
my family and my kids, we
all, they love the part where
the hippo eats Jack Black
every time, but yeah,
(Dwayne laughs)
it's weird, I don't want kids like that?
That's weird, but -
- All kids love that part, by the way.
- (Kelly) That's so weird.
- Yes, they love that part.
- It's a little Jeffrey
Dahmer, but yeah, yeah.
It's a little weird.
- But you go with it.
- (Kelly) Yeah, I go with it.